es ist soweit
ist das nicht ein bisschen früh verließ
liegt auch noch überall schnee
der frühling ist da ist los geht's
der mann hat schlitten fahren
fahren der frühling ist da die
grillsaison ist eröffnet hat mit dem
wetter sicheren wollen den sie an
grillen im mai oder was a la shoah zur
rallye hallo gehört in der früh hobby zu
sabine gesagt bei dem wetter da müssen
wir unbedingt grillen und da ist ja
schon da ist
tourismus ist auch eine
lebenseinstellung
machst denn du da ich schließe das bad
wir grillen heute wir machen was wir
grillen es ist frühling
frühling das wäre dann würde nicht mal
am nordpol als frühling durchgehend seit
das ist mir vollkommen klar besser
lebenseinstellung der hinter einer
politischen immer nach unten also eher
zeitlos wir brauchen fleisch gebrauch
und kohle und und tisch muss das becken
um was geht es denn hier überhaupt es
geht darum dass wir früher heuer an
gewinnen wird der teddy maier da drüben
also der debatte meyer da drüben laut
seiner frau ist der depp hatte mayer ein
richtig netter kerl und ein richtiger
schatz weil er für seine frau kocht
wieso machst du das eigentlich nicht
warum sie für seine frau cora
die kinder die frau ohne
kochen wieder mal für dich also bitte
erst macht ist was aber gesagt hat okay
unter hartinger läuft es bei ihnen läuft
erstklassig heute wird angegeben und
sowie sascha für die ersten in der
nachbarschaft der deshalb macht um das
geht doch gar nicht
umsonst 0
natürlich geht es darum geht wie ich
sagt er besorgen wetter nicht angriff
werde der kunde nicht ganz dicht sein
bei uns ist das immer ein riesen event
bekommen sämtliche freunde dass
mindestens 10 15 like a man da also bei
uns ist das ein event also wichtiger
super mega event eigentlich aber hat mir
so familien super mega
express langsam
[Musik]
o
so bitten
dein fazit
hier schafft zeigt linken hat denn du
schon wieder
irgendwelche privaten sehr hertingen
werden bestimmt noch einen grillanzünder
rumliegen von unserem alten grill also
menschen die grillanzünder herrn immer
wissen was das für menschen für mich
sagen dass an menschen töten
ernsten her
das ist wirklich sehr nett anna so
schnell wie das sie hinter uns bringen
um so weniger frost wollen holen wir uns
es muss ja nicht jeder so viel geld
ausgeben für einen grill wie mein martin
london london modell unseres autoren
kobel spex ist diese kritik
wies er ein spezielles fans und ganz
einfache bratwürste geht keiner kann die
so zuverlässig verbrennen wie er sie
nicht mehr halt wenn es mir mal mit dem
scheiß grillanzünder geht bereich
elektrik
jetzt braucht ihr bier
da niemals brands waren mir bitte sehr
dankeschön
leck mich am arsch
keine ahnung das ist eingefroren
beim angrillen hier hat sagt es ist
frühling
das ist ein crash am original indien
pale ale dies machen freunde von uns
case start-up messer
und wo freunde bleiben ja nie freunde
eigentlich das stimmt und bleiben unsere
freunde ein
das haben wir uns abgesagt haben auch
abgesagt so viel
als weicheier
wen wundert's denen ist zu kalt
qualität sieht es da war auch schon
ein echter bayer zittert nicht vor kälte
der zittert vor wut weil es nicht kälter
ist wenn er uns gold nur seine aussagen
seien nur seid einfach grün gesetzt ist
der muss eine familie versorgen
ich gehe einkaufen ich mache den salat
ich stecke den tisch ich liebe das
fleisch ein ich übergebe das fleisch und
er legt es auf bin dann gehe ich in die
küche hohe den salat die saucen und wenn
ich zurückkomme sage ich bescheid dass
das fleisch anbrennt und nach dem essen
römmich den tisch ab ich räume die
spülmaschine ein und der grimme ist aber
draußen gelobt dass es so großartig
gekocht hat apropos ich glaub die steaks
seien jetzt durch
jetzt folgendes jahr hat mit mir noch zu
erstens eine kühle jetzt ihre wird auf
meinem grill dieses gut gelaufen und um
das bier auf dem grill
immerhin seien mir zwar dieses jahr die
ersten
und startete
wir haben vom letzten wochenende vom
gründer und ganzen haufen fleisch übrig
haben alle freuen brief einfach vorbei
moment wie vom letzten wochen in japan
china weder darum einfach unwissenheit
bei sonderseiten
schöne scheiße
ja wenigstens diese spielchips blick
[Musik]